hello everyone thanks thanks for coming
my name is mark seaman and
if you want to know more about me
there's information there on blog.dk
so so this talk is about
software development productivity so
that's a problem that we often need to
solve
at least you know most of us
don't really feel that we are as
productive as software developers as
we'd like to be and
in general our managers and other
stakeholders tend to believe that we're
not nearly as productive as we ought to
be um so that's um that's the um problem
that i'm
going to try to address today and i'm
not going to say i'm not going to claim
that that's the only problem that we
have in software development i'm also
not going to claim that the
solution that i'm going to propose is
the only way to address that problem far
from it
but we just have to start at one place
and sort of
work from there
so why aren't we as productive as we'd
like to be and there's probably lots of
different reasons for that
but one of them is that we spend a lot
of time reading existing code
you could say we waste a lot of time
reading existing code so robertson
martin for example
writes in one of his books the ratio of
time spent reading versus writing is
well over ten to one
and
i don't know where i get where i get
those numbers from i think he may just
pull them out of a hat
but i think you know still um
the ratios you know sounds
you know fair let's just go with that
for an example anyway it's a way to talk
about things
um so um
what happens to your productivity if
this is true and where should you
prioritize your effort
now one way we can try to illustrate
that is with a little graph like this
one
so i have you know 10 orange boxes
representing the time that you are
spending
reading code and then one green box
representing the time you're spending
writing new code
and that's a ten to one ratio
so often when you have
software vendors or language designers
or library authors
talk about productivity they will often
tell you that you need to um they will
often tell you that you have they have
solutions for you that will enable you
to write code faster or you know write
code in a more efficient manner
so um if you just you know
hypothetically imagine that you could in
you know decrease the time you have to
spend writing code with 50 you know with
with 50
or you know you can actually well that's
a doubling of um
of um of productivity um but if you
could do that that's sort of like a
hypothetical experiment that you know
thought experiment that's not actually
going to happen um but that would mean
you know that's a 50 reduction in in the
time you spend writing code
and as we can tell from this graph
that's probably not really you know
that's that that sounds like a lot but
it's really more like 4.5 percent
and you know 50 that's probably not
going to happen
that's not really realistic you know you
can get you know
improvements in efficiency in in terms
of writing software and so on
but probably not by 50
now don't get me wrong i am i'll take
all the improvements that i can get so
uh you know if i have a vendor that
comes out with a new ide that i think is
better than the one that i'm using at
the moment i'll take that uh if there's
a new language that comes comes around
that or you know language features that
come around that makes me more
productive fine i'll take all of that
it's just that i don't think we should
um imagine or you know
we shouldn't be under the illusion that
those things are really what's gonna
matter in terms of our productivity if
we want to be more productive
there is a you know the elephant in the
room is we have to do something about
readability if we can you know decrease
the time we spend reading existing code
we can actually become much more
productive and so that's uh that's what
this talk is about now um
how do you write readable code and how
do you determine whether code is
readable or not
um
that's not that's not an easy question
to answer but but let's try to look at
an example so um here's some some
example code and i would claim that this
is readable
and then someone else would come by and
say well that's it it's completely
unreadable because it's the sharp code
and or maybe i put the curly brackets in
the wrong place and that's unreadable
for that for those reasons or whatever
um
but you know that's not really gonna
you know help us to move forward if we
have those um discussions that are
basically you know based on opinion so
we you know one person could say i
really like this this is readable code
because i wrote it and then someone else
would come by and say i don't like this
at all you know
for various reasons and then the first
one will say but it is readable and the
next one will say no it's not um so this
kind of kindergarten you know level of
you know discussion is not really what's
going to take us further so we need to
have a you know we need to
instrumentalize the way that we can talk
about these things um so so we we need
to have a vocabulary that we can use in
order to you know figure out is this
readable or not
so um
um what i'm going to try to do is to
talk you through you know what happens
in the brain when we you know are
exposed to code like this
so all code that i'm going to show you
here is from my book code that fits in
your brain code the vision head sorry
which is right here
and um
it's the same code base that goes
as an example all the way through the
book and that's also the code that
you're going to see here
it's an online restaurant a reservation
system
which is a rest api never mind that's
not really that important but just if
you wanted
all right so what happens if we are you
know confronted with code that we
haven't seen before
so um what uh most research seems to
indicate is that you the brain starts to
engage in a process called tracing or
you know basically cognitive compilation
it's as though you know we in the brain
are trying to run a little interpreter
or an emulator trying to understand you
know what happens in this code what
happens if if you know um this value is
that and and so on
so the brain tries to you know to make
sense of these things
um so um
i'm going to spend some time talking
about this code and the point is i'm i'm
trying to talk about you know what
happens in the brain and you know
how we read code so it's it sounds like
i'm walking you through the algorithm
which is actually not the point i'm
walking you through how do we actually
read and understand code
so one of the things we might notice is
first of all okay so this is a method it
has a name it's called allocate
it returns an innumerable of table uh
takes an iron mobile reservation as
input so if there are any people in this
audience who are not
you know dot net developers ionum mobile
is basically just a collection
um and reservation and table are you
know objects domain objects that we
haven't seen yet um i'm actually not
going to show you those
um but then you know when we start
tracing through the code you know this
cognitive compilation will notice that
one of the things that happens here is
that there's this object called
allocation
which is a list of table
and
a list object in net is something that
can change state we can you know erase
all the elements inside of the list or
we can add new things to it or we can
remove or reorder things and do all
sorts of things
so if we're trying to understand what's
happening in this code we we might
notice that hey this is something that i
need to keep track of you know that's
this made this has state
and this state may change
and since i haven't scanned through the
rest of the code yet i haven't actually
figured out whether the state of this
object may impact whether i go in one
way or the other so you know keeping
track of state is really important
because otherwise i can't you know
cognitively compile the code
so that's one thing to keep keep track
of
now
there's a for each loop and if
reservation is is empty we just fall all
the way through and we don't and you
know execute any of the indented code
on the other hand if we have at least
one object in reservations we will now
try to find a table in the allocation
that fits a particular reservation
quantity
and you know the find method will return
null if it can't find anything so we
have to check for that as well
so this little thing where it says if
table is curly brackets
that's sort of like a c sharp little
pawn basically that means if if table is
something basically meaning if table is
not null
so we're checking for null there and if
it's null if it's not something again we
fall through and we don't execute the
indented code but otherwise
we do indeed you know execute the
indented code so we remove a table we
remove the table that we found from the
allocation and add it back in but then
now with the reservation associated with
it
so there's a little bit of local state
mutation going on here but it's sort of
like it's okay we're keeping track of
one thing in our brain and and that
seems to be fairly okay
so to summarize the three pathways
through the code and some of you will
probably also already recognize that
that's this is called this kind of
analysis is called cyclomatic complexity
so cyclomatic complexity basically gives
you this idea you know how many
different pathways are there through the
code and you can think of that as um
as sort of like three
different execution paths that all
coexist at the same time so it's almost
like three dimensions sort of
superimposed on top of each other so if
we have cyclomatic complexity too large
um
we're probably gonna going to get
overloaded mentally if we're trying to
understand what's going on and likewise
if we have to keep track of too much
stuff you know too many variables like
allocation then we're probably going to
get overloaded our brains will probably
not be able to you know perform that
cognitive compilation of the code
because we're not able to trace through
the code
um so the problem is the question is uh
now we have at least two ways of
quantifying you know the complexity of
code i have cyclomatic complexity and i
also have this thing where we can ask
ourselves you know how many objects do
we need to keep track of in order to
understand what's happening
and it seems like this code is you know
we have cyclomatic complexity of three
and we have basically one mutable object
that we're keeping track of so that
sounds like it's probably okay and i
would claim that this is okay because
the threshold is a little bit higher you
know what fits in our short-term memory
and there's a lot of research that seems
to indicate that maybe we can keep track
of about seven things in our short-term
memory
this is based on a paper by george
miller called the magical number seven
plus minus two which dates back from
1956 based on lots of experiments with
with people you know where they were
asked to keep track of various different
things in their short-term memory
so the limit you know sits around seven
uh we can keep track of about seven
things in our short-term memory
now
miller didn't
he miller wanted to and ask people to
you know keep track of various different
things you ask ask them to remember
random numbers for example and but you
could also ask people to remember other
things for example colors and so on so
it doesn't have to be numbers uh we
could you know actually think about
these things as just you know what we
call chunks of information so it doesn't
have to be you know very primitive
numbers like digits for example but it
could actually be words or colors or you
know
things in the physical world so while i
keep talking i'm just going to switch
over here and start a little animation
so
we can keep track about you know seven
things in our short-term memory
when you start a completely new code
base when you write the first you know
hello world you know line of code that
may be one thing
and that you know sort of fits in your
short term memory but as you add more
and more decisions more and more you
know features to your code base
you very quickly come to a point where
there's more than seven things going on
you know a realistic code base probably
has you know seven thousand things going
on and maybe seven million things going
on there's way more than that you can
fit in your short-term memory
so the question is you know how do we
deal with that you know how do we deal
with the fact that there's going to be
much more going on in a code base than
fits in our short-term memory
so basically as far as i can tell we
have two options
either we can rely on long-term memory
or you know the other option i'll get
back to in a moment
so i think relying on long-term memory
that's long-term memory is a completely
different
kind of beast long-term memory no one
really knows exactly what the capacity
of it is it's not that precise you can
actually you know warp and and forget
things or remember things wrong and and
things like that but it seems like it
has a really big capacity
and i remember i was once you know
engaged with a client
who wanted me to help them with their
legacy code base
and i got to interview some of the
people on the team and
and one of the one of the people
one of the team members that i got a
chance to talk to was the newest member
of the of the team he had been there for
two two two years
so i asked him so when you started
i was still recent in his memory when
you
started um how long did it take you
before you could you know you felt that
you could
do something in this code base on your
own without help from your you know your
peers and he said well that took me
three three months he you know he didn't
even hesitate he said three months
um so i think he spent those three
months you know painstakingly trying to
commit the structure of that code base
to his long-term memory which is you
know quite uh you know maybe not
infinite but you know arbitrarily large
um so that sort of works it's just that
it's a lot it takes a lot of time and
this is one of the reasons why we spend
a lot of time reading existing code
because there's just a lot of stuff to
commit to your long-term memory and in
order to if you know effect efficiently
you know commit something to your
long-term memory you have to you know
study it and keep on repeating the
exercise in order to understand how
things work
um
and another problem we have with
long-term memory is that once we've
committed something to long-term memory
it's always tends to stay there
so once you've understood how you know
the structure of a large-scale code base
once you've committed that to long-term
memory then if one of your colleagues
come by and changes things the code no
longer fits the
mental image you have of it and now it
becomes even more difficult to reconcile
what you have in your long-term memory
with the current state of the code so
again you have to sort of re-read things
over and over again so while it's
possible to work with the code base that
where you know thousands or millions of
things are going on you sort of have to
rely on your long-term memory and that
slows you down so that's one of the
options to deal with this sort of
problem now the other option to deal
with this problem is to say well what if
we wanted what if we decided that
instead of relying on long-term memory
we could rely on our short-term memory
that would that would make a you know a
lot of things much easier because our
short-term memory is sort of ephemeral
uh you know you load something into your
short-term memory and you keep it around
you know long enough that you
can do whatever it is that you need to
do with that information and then as
soon as you you know go and do something
else you forget about that stuff as well
so what if we could structure the code
in such a way that we could you know
load it in you know when we look at it
it all fits in short-term memory
and
then we can work with it we can do what
it is that we'd like to do without you
know using our short-term memory and
then once we've you know
committed the change to git and pushed
it away we can go and do something else
and we forget about it and that means
you know the next time we come by and
look at that code it takes a couple of
minutes to sort of reload it into your
to your brain again to your short-term
memory um but but you don't have to
engage your long-term memory and that
also means that if someone else you know
what if one of your colleagues came by
at the same time
and changed that code you're not being
confused because you've you've already
forgotten about it so when you see it
again you know if the colleague also
tried to
respect the cognitive constraints of our
short-term memory then you should you
should be able to read the code and you
know deal with it using your short term
memory
now while i've been talking about this
you've noticed that this grid is
starting to take shape here
i
added a lot of those chunks and i just
keep you know this simulation just keeps
on adding things
and you can see that it starts to
resemble you know honeycomb so what
happens if we say well we need to you
know isolate at most seven things
and um
and just deal with that so i'm going to
switch back here and if we isolate at
most seven things we get a figure that
that looks like this
so um so i call this a hex flower
because it looks a little bit like a
flower but just made up
out of hexagons and you can think of
that as each of those cells representing
basically a register in your short-term
memory so your short-term memory is a
byte
a 7-bit byte that is that was a thing
once
so that's what you have to do with
so if we want to
you know instrumentalize or make it a
little bit more objective in the way we
talk about whether or not code is
readable
we should you know think about you know
how can we respect that cognitive
constraint and we can use this you know
little
figure here as a symbol of that so just
to be clear i'm not saying that you know
the the magical number seven plus minus
two is not you know seven is not that
magical
most of what i'm going to say here is
doesn't really rely on the number being
exactly seven you know it could be five
or
nine or whatever
but um but seven gives us this nice
figure as well so i'm just going to go
with that
all right so um when we look at code
we are going to look at code at various
different levels of abstraction
and you know the cognitive constraints
that we can only deal with seven things
in our short-term memory you know that
always applies you know our brain
doesn't care about the level of
abstraction of the code that we're
looking at so if we want to respect you
know the limitations of our short-term
memory we should always structure code
so that that there's the most seven
things going on because otherwise we
can't trace the code
but there's gonna be you know deeper
levels of abstraction so if you're
looking at things at a high level of
abstraction we also understand that each
of those cells let's say
the the upper right one that's going to
contain you know more complexity so if
we want to zoom in on that you know
again at that level it needs to respect
the constraint that we can keep track of
of most seven things uh so again we
should be able to do that at you know
all sorts of levels of abstraction so
again if we zoom in again we might
actually encounter some real code
so i chose to start with this create
method because this is sort of like the
the lowest level of detail uh this
there's not a lot of abstraction hidden
behind this so this is a
this is a method that sits on a class
that has the responsibility of you know
saving and retrieving data from a
database from a sql server database
um so you could ask yourself again the
question is this code readable you know
does it fit in your short-term memory
and now that we have a few ways of
instrumentalizing or quantifying these
things we can you know start to ask
those questions you know what for
example what's the cyclomatic complexity
of of this code and the cyclomatic
complexity is two there's two pathways
through this code either reservation is
null
and that results in one outcome and all
reservation is not null and that results
in another outcome and i know that there
might be exceptions thrown so i'm just
going to ignore that for now for various
reasons uh so we can say the cyclomatic
complexity is two so that's sort of like
two uh you know parallel
dimensions that exists superimposed on
top of each other we can probably keep
track of that if we can keep track of
seven things
um this method represents two different
things
um so that's that's one thing that we
could try to do uh so in that you know
if we if we if we choose to use that
measurement we could say this is
readable because there's less than seven
things going on
but there might be other things going on
so what we can also do is you know i
talked about this thing where we do
tracing and we try to keep track of you
know object state
so what we can do is as a very crude you
know kind of measurement we can count
all the variables so we can say uh well
so there's the restaurant id that's a
perimeter um that's that's a very very
blah that's so that's the thing we need
to keep track of
there's a reservation there's another
parameter we need to keep track of that
there's something called the connection
string that we use to create a sql
connection so that's a string uh it's uh
it's actually a read-only property and
for those of you who are not you know
c-sharp developers a property here is
just a glorified class field so just
think of it like that but it's it's read
only so it can't change and you know
strings in general don't change
so this just contains information about
you know how to connect to the database
and we use that to create a connection
object and i'll just keep keep on
counting here create reservation sql is
another string that contains the actual
you know t sql code that will be
executed against the database and we use
that and the connection to create a
command object so and and then you know
from there on there no more you know
variables so that's all the variables
that are in scope here
um
so um so after that you know if we trace
things you know how many things are
actually changing state so the command
object changes state six times because
we add you know parameters we bind each
of the parameters to that values um but
it's it's quite easy to follow
and then you know towards the end where
we go contact open async we actually
change the state of the connection as
well so it you know starts off being
closed and now it's open
but
but it's it's quite easy to follow
because that's not too much stuff going
on
and um so again if we if we think of
seven as being the limits that we have
you know there's you know there's fewer
things going on here so it fits in our
in our head
um
before we move on you might say okay but
really you know something like
restaurant id the one that i've labeled
one
with the number one
that's a mute that's an integer that's
immutable it's not going to change state
so we don't really need to keep track of
the state of it because it's not going
to change
and the same thing goes for the
connection string and the create
reservation sql those label three and
five
there are strings they're immutable
they're not going to change
so really if you want to be a little bit
more sophisticated you can say all right
so we only need to keep track of three
things reservation
con and command
but then again if you go and actually
read the implementation of the
reservation class you'll notice that
that's a
an immutable object uh it's a value
object and it's a domain object that i
created in that particular way because i
know that immutable you know objects
have a lot of benefits and one of them
is that you you know that they're not
going to change so you don't really have
to expend that much mental energy to
sort of you know when you're trying to
understand what the code does you don't
have to you know worry does it change
because you know it's not going to
change so really there's only two things
that that will change the command object
and the and the the connection and the
command objects and they actually do
change here
so if we want to be more sophisticated
we could argue there's only really two
things going on so this is very readable
for that reason it fits in your head
but if we're just being crude we just
count all the variables because this is
easier you know you don't need a tool
for that you can just do that when
you're looking at the code
so we can try to enumerate all of those
or we can you know try to assign each of
those
variables to each of those you know
cells in the higgs flower and we can say
okay they all fit
there we have room for seven we only
used six
so we have wicked this fits in our head
for that reason
all right so um so the
hex flower here is basically a symbol of
you know things that that fit in your
head
now
i showed you i you know i start start by
showing you this create method because
that's sort of like the lowest level of
granularity there's really a lot not a
lot of user code hidden behind that that
thing there's only framework code like
you know sql connection sql command and
things like that you typically don't go
and read the code of a framework code
but then you might say well you know but
at a higher level of abstraction
we have code that calls that create
method that we just looked at
and if there's you know if there are six
variables involved in understanding what
the create method does doesn't that
compound you know if we look at it from
the next level so if you imagine that
we're looking at it from from the next
level now and you know in one of those
cells we have this create method sitting
that you know uses you know six
uh you know variables in itself and then
we have something else sitting in one of
the other cells because we are calling
another method and that you know maybe
represents you know complexity of four
and then you can add ten and four
together that you know exceeds that
blows the budget
so you can't do that so it's very very
important
to make sure to design the code in such
a way that when when you zoom out and
look at things at a higher level of
abstraction you know what looks you know
a little bit complex
at the detail level should just you know
become one thing it should become one
chunk you know you should somehow be
able to represent that in your brain as
being just one thing because otherwise
it doesn't work
so you should be able to zoom out uh you
know one level or you should be able to
you know keep on zooming out
in your in your code base and every time
you look at a higher level of
abstraction you know you still have to
you know take into account that the
brain is organized in the way that it
does and it has the limitations that the
brain actually has
so i'm going to return to the problem or
the question of you know how do you
assign things so that they um
that they don't leak their complexity
but i'm going to do this in
10 minutes 10 15 minutes i'm going to
talk about something else first so
again we we looked at the most uh
detailed level of granularity on the
other hand we also want to be able to
zoom out to you know basically um maybe
the entry point of the application and
say
we also need to organize code at a very
high level of abstraction so that it
fits in our head
so if you've ever worked with asp.net
core you've probably seen code like this
this is basically generated by wizard i
didn't write this code myself i just had
you know visual studio write it
for me but we can still sort of analyze
and see does this fit in our head so
first of all if you know a little bit
about asp.net.com you don't have to for
this talk but if you did you probably
know that all the interesting stuff will
happen inside a class called startup and
we look at that in a moment but
otherwise we can try to enumerate you
know what else is going on here and
there's really only three things so
it's that's that's that's good um we
don't have a problem with this with this
main entry point
now if we're interested in the startup
class
we want to be able to have a look at
that so we're looking at a thing that
has a slightly um you know um a slightly
more granular level of abstraction and
again if we want to if we hope that this
code is organized in the same way that
it respects our short-term memory limit
we shouldn't have if we go and look at
startup we shouldn't have to remember
that there's arcs and web builder
involved
so it's also very important to make sure
that whenever you zoom in and something
all all the surrounding stuff stuff sort
of goes out of scope in terms of you
know what you have to you know require
of your brain
so this is the public api of the startup
class we can just again simply enumerate
those two methods here that's a
constructor that takes a configuration
object and then you know later on
exposes that configuration object so
again if we try to enumerate that that's
basically things you know three things
going on
so that fits now configure services uh
again i'm not trying to talk you through
how this organ this application is
organized i'm mostly trying to give you
some examples of you know how do you
organize code so that you keep on
respecting that there can't be more than
you know approximately seven things
going on
so again you can try to have this little
quantification where you can say well
how can we can we discuss whether
something like what we're looking at
right now is this readable or not so you
could ask again you know various
questions like you know what's the
cyclomatic complexity of this thing you
know how many you know alternative
pathways do we have through this code
and there's no branching there's no
looping so we basically just you know
run all the way through
um i know there's a little bit you know
towards the end there that you can't see
um i'm going to reveal that in a moment
but there's no surprises there trust me
on that so cyclomatic complexity of one
that's as low as you can get so so
that's fine we can also try to enumerate
again just the crude thing of
enumerating all the you know the
variables that are involved and it turns
out that we have six of those as well so
so we're good on that account
now i want to stress here that you know
these measurements that i'm talking
about these attempts at quantification
like cyclomatic complexity or counting
the variables and you know other things
like that you might also want to look at
your lines of code
you probably have to divide that into
segments in order to make it you know
fit with seven but that's a different
story now but what i want to say about
this is that you know
this is
um
you know these these things are not
there in order to be
rigid rules
these are you know
tools you can use in order to give
yourself a vocabulary so that you can
discuss things with your colleagues if
you if you want to have a discussion
with a colleague you know where is where
you feel
that you know a particular method that
you're looking at is growing too
complicated and you want to split it up
into you know a couple of helper methods
and the other car your colleagues you
know says well that's i don't feel that
way you know again if one says you know
i feel this and the other one says i
feel that you you're not having a
discussion you just you know you're at
the kindergarten level so you need to
have some sort of vocabulary where you
can talk about these things and this is
a way you can talk about these things
now again you have to agree uh on the
premise here but but it moves you a
little bit you know closer to being able
to actually have good discussions about
code
right so i would say this code is
readable for for those various reasons
um
so as you can tell towards the end here
there's nothing you know more
interesting going on there so towards
the end what we basically have is a
table of contents so we're still working
on a very high level of abstraction in
the sense that there's nothing that
really tells you what's going on in the
you know the details of the system but
it's sort of like it's it's like a table
of contents that tell you you know why
where can you go if you want to learn
about you know various different things
so for example if this is a risk api if
you want to know whether or not you need
to you know log on in order to be able
to use this rest api or if it allows you
know anonymous access you might say okay
configure authorization that sounds like
a reasonable you know next
place to visit
so maybe you want to go and have a look
at that method
now when you do that again you know all
this this stuff that surrounds it at the
moment shouldn't you know be important
if you go and look at configure
authorization only what happens inside
of configure authorization should be you
know important so what you see is all
there is uh as a condiment says
the same thing goes with configure
repository you know if you wanna you
know about the persistence system in in
this um
in this code base you might go there and
again when you go there you should have
this expectation that you don't have to
understand what happened in configure
authorization or what's later on gonna
happen in configure clock you know if
you go to configure repository you
should again be met with a you know
a piece of code that respects uh the
limitations of your short-term memory so
at most seven things should be going on
so this is sort of just an idea that
keeps on repeating this is a little bit
of an ad hoc enumeration
but the idea is that you should always
have um
[Music]
you know if you can organize the code so
that there's no more than seven things
going on you know you have a much better
chance of
not having to rely that much on the
long-term memory and you can mostly rely
on your short-term memory
now
i promise to get back to this question
of how do we ensure that things that
have you know a level of complexity at
one level of abstraction when we look at
it from the next level out
it should just look like one thing
because otherwise we you know we can't
have you know complexity leak through
because if if that's uh if that happens
the code uh no longer fits in our head
so um so we can you know again imagine
that one of those cells is represented
for example by this allocate method that
we looked at before
and
i would claim that this the method not
only fits in your head but it also
collapses into one thing you know you
can actually you know as viewed from the
outside you can think of that as just
one chunk of information
and there's a reason for that
now the first
before we do that let's talk a little
bit about the complexity just to recap
so we already established that the
cyclomatic complexity of this method is
three
so that's fine that's well within the
limit limits of of our short-term memory
but again if you imagine that this
complexity leaks through you know if you
have to think about all three
you know states all three behaviors of
this method you know superimposed on
each other if you have to think of that
when you call the allocate method that
means that you know you already expended
three out of your budget of seven uh in
your calling code so you can't really
allow that sort of you know complexity
to um to escape
the scope of of the implementation
details
and
again also if we want to use this
accrued method of just enumerating all
the objects i know there's really only
one object that can actually change
state but if we just use the crude
method of counting all the things you'll
notice that there are six of those as
well so you may be wondering now you
know why why why are there always six
things in all the examples that i've
shown you and the reasons for that is
that all the code that i've written for
the book i've you know i followed these
this principle where you know whenever
whenever i started to get near a
threshold of seven i would refactor the
code so that i would uh always be you
know
almost always be um
below seven in terms of complexity so
often you know if i have something where
you know there's six of something going
on i'm just setting i'm just letting it
sit as it is and then you know if i add
a seventh thing i would often go and you
know
prematurely refactor it so that it's
ready to be um changed again in the
future
that's a little bit of a digression
though
but again you know if we have six things
going on here we can't let you know that
knowledge um that there's six six things
going on you know you should not as a
caller if you want to call the allocate
method you should not be required
to understand that there are those six
things going on because again if if
that's a requirement
the code is not going to fit in your
short-term memory
so
when we look at allocate from the
outside it must you know compact it must
you know collapse into just one chunk of
information that's how we need our
brains to be able to treat it that way
and i believe that i can make the
argument that this code you know fits
that description so the first the first
thing is that this code has no side
effects
this particular method
we can go look go back and look for side
effects so side effects are all the
things that change the state of the
system
so if you you know write a file as a
disk that changes the state of the
system
if you send an email to a customer that
changes the state of the system if
you're repainting something on the on
the monitor that actually changes the
state of the system um so that's you
know if you write to the console that
changes the state of the system
maybe okay so there's a little bit of a
philosophical discussion there it's it's
sort of like you know if a tree falls in
a in a forest and no one's around you
know does it make a sound so it's a
little bit like that you know if you if
you log to the console
but no one looks at the console it's not
actually a side effect does that count
or not so you can sort of have those
discussions because there's always going
to be the side effect of code executing
that you know um
you know electrons are going to move
around in the physical world so you know
some sort of side effect you always have
will have
but you know noticeable side effects
there's there's no emails being sent
here there's no uh you know
files being written there's no you know
screens being repainted here
just uh some calculation stuff going on
so there's no side effects here so
that's that's one thing another property
that this code has is that um
it's deterministic
so we define that as having the you know
the same inputs will always produce the
same outputs
let's go back and have a look at that
again so what are typical sources of
determinist to non-deterministic
behavior
so for example if you rely on the system
clock
now that's non-deterministic because the
time changes all the time so if you have
code that relies on you know
it does it it does you know a different
thing if it's sunday then if it's monday
that's non-deterministic behavior or you
know if it checks the dates or you know
the year or things like that you know
that's not deterministic because it
relies on the system clock
the same thing goes for random numbers
if you have any sort of random number
generator involved that's
non-deterministic it's almost you know a
tautology there
but also if you do any sort of reading
from io if you read from a file or if
you read from a database that's also
non-deterministic because you know
imagine reading from a file the input is
the file name
and you can go and read from the file
and you return the contents and then you
have the same action one more time the
same file name but then the contents of
the file has changed in the meantime so
now you return something else
you know by the definition the same
input should always produce the same
output that's non-deterministic if
you're reading from a file
so anything that that performs i o so
reading from a file you know querying a
database you know querying a you know a
web service all of that uh is also out
of the picture
that's nondeterministic behavior but we
have none of that here
there's no random numbers being
generated we don't rely on the system
clock we don't do i o
okay
so together
we now have two properties you know we
we have no side effects and we have
deterministic behavior we we call that a
pure function
and this is interesting in terms of
whether or not you know details leak
because you know pure functions are what
we call referentially transparent and
what that what does that mean so
referential transparency means that the
function call is equal to its result
so you know this from mathematics you
know that you know two plus two is
always full
and if i ask you for example you know
what's
four times five you'd probably say it's
and how did you know that
now
you probably didn't actually perform the
calculation though the calculation here
is that you go
um
5 plus 5 plus 5 plus 5. you do that you
know four times that's the calculation
but you don't have to do that because
you've memorized the multiplication
table
because the result is all you need you
don't have you don't need to do the
calculation you just need the result
and this is sort of the same thing here
is that if you know the inputs already
then then you don't need to perform the
calculation you can just you know use
the result so the result is the same as
the function
so going back to allocate here this is a
pure function
and that means
we can regard all of this stuff as being
just um
equal to the output that produces it
produces an innumerable table that's
basically a collection of tables
so
we don't really need to understand
exactly how it arrives at that is we
just need to understand that you know
the output of this function is just one
thing it's a collection of tables so
that's a chunk of information a
collection of tables we can think of
that as being one thing
so referential transparency is is a
really good way of making sure that
things you know that complexity doesn't
leak you know you can have a
a pure function that has cyclomatic
complexity of 73 if all you if if that's
what you want but if it produces a
single output and what else can it do if
it's a function now
that thing is just one output and and
you don't have to think about you know
how did it arrive at that you know
output you can just think about it as
the as the chunk of information
um that's not you know you can't write
everything as pure functions you also
need other things as well but you know
in general we can say
how do we you know design things so that
you know the complexity that's you know
inside of a thing doesn't leak through
you know we haven't we have a word for
that it's called encapsulation you know
this is the idea behind object-oriented
encapsulation is that you are not
supposed to be you know to understand
the inner workings of an object you just
you're just supposed to be able to
interact with it with and not caring
about how it's implemented
and if you want to implement it you go
and have a look at that implementation
but then you don't have to care about
the callers or the environment just the
inputs and the output
so so in general encapsulation and more
specifically you know write as many pure
functions as as you can that's really
going to help you you know follow this
design principle of not having too many
things going on
all right so to summarize uh we need to
be able to you know
organize code so that at every level you
know whether we zoom in or out
it should be organized so that it
respects our short term memory capacity
and which is you know about seven
we should be able to zoom in as we did
before we should be able to zoom all the
way out um to the
to the entry point
but if we think about you know just some
arbitrary level of abstraction here you
know
again our brains don't care about the
abstraction level we we just need to
make sure that we
respect the the constraints that we
actually have in our brain
now
obviously we understand that even if we
organize the code in such a way that
there are only seven things going on you
know
within you know behind each of those you
know seven cells that we're looking at
here
there might be more things going on it's
very likely that that's the case so you
might you know for example you know at
the most if we respect this design
principle all the way through you know
at the next level down there's 49 things
going on
but we just don't you know have to think
about that in our short-term memory but
that's actually the case but then you
know each of each of those you know
seven cells might again you know contain
another higgs flower and each of those
hex flowers might contain another hex
flower
so this this is a fractal you know i
call that the hicks flower fractal and
if you came here and thought you know
fractal architecture is something with
mantle broad sets or things like that
and you think this is not a fractal um
here's another fractal that's very well
known within the mathematical
communities it's called the
snowflake it's quite obvious why it's
called the snowflake but uh you probably
noticed that we basically just take
each uh straight line and we subdivide
it by adding you know a little you know
triangular hump on it and then we just
keep on doing that so you can keep on
zooming in on the um on the edge of the
snowflake and it'll just keep keep
on repeating the same pattern um you
know
forever you know i stopped rendering at
about five or six levels deep here but
that's the idea and the same thing goes
with the hex you know the higgs flower
fractal here i stopped rendering after
four levels deep because if i add a
fifth level i've tried uh then it
basically just becomes one green blob uh
so it's not that interesting to look at
um
but anyway that's that's sort of why i
call it fractal architecture because
it's actually they are fractals but it's
more like a way of thinking about you
know how to structure code uh so that it
sort of you know keeps on um
respecting this uh self-repeating uh
self-similar pattern at all levels of
abstraction
um
because we only have that much that much
compa you know capacity in our brain in
our short term memory you can keep track
of seven things so we should write code
that you know
you know respects that in a code that
fits in your head which which is also
the title of my new book which is right
here
and you can get it wherever good books
are sold so um
that's basically what i have but i am i
you know i left rooms for some questions
and answers and then if you don't have
any questions and answers you can get
you know out of the room before everyone
else um but for those of you who might
be interested i brought two copies of
the book and i'm going to give them a
wave for people who ask you know nice
questions and i'm not going to be too
discriminate so basically the first two
people who get you know asks a decent
question will will get the copy of the
book um
so um you can ask me basically you know
something about the talk or you can ask
me about anything else but if you have
you know questions about something else
maybe wait with those until later
so um are there any questions
yes sir
from
within the class
does
that not end up kind of you need to
understand
the restrictions of
the class like the level higher above to
know
whether or not that property is going to
have an impact because maybe someone
could come and try and change it
right so
me so let me try to rephrase this so
that everyone else can hear it and also
to see if i understood the question
correctly so in one of the examples i
show i'm using a read-only property you
know the connection string i suppose
that's the one you're thinking about
oh yeah there's another example where
where i use a you know collection of
tables and i turn that into a list
that is also a read-only property by the
way um so your question is you know if
if i'm sort of taking you know you know
properties or class fields into scope in
my method um
is is that a problem
and um and you know what what happens if
you know if other people come and change
that later on
yeah so so yeah so so you further on say
that you know in order in order for all
of that to fit in my brain i have to
understand that this is a read-only
property and it's sort of available in
the class um fair enough yeah um
i think you know at the level of um
analysis that i showed you know it's
it's definitely a variable that it's in
scope uh so in that case it it just
counts towards my budget if you will and
that's what i did um but you can also
say at a slightly you know if you take
one step back and look at the you know
the overall object um the object should
fit in your in your head as well in in
the sense that you need to um
you need to understand you know what's
actually available in the object you
know what what sort of you know
read-only properties are there or you
know settable properties if that's the
case and what members are actually there
so i think this
this way of looking at things applies to
all sorts of different levels you know i
showed you the public api of the startup
class for example because i think it's
important to also organize objects so
that
if when you look at the public api you
don't want a list of 42 methods
that you know is exposed by a given
object because then you know it becomes
difficult to fit in your head again
because there's just too much stuff
going on and also it's pretty likely
that an object like that's a god object
that has low cohesion so it should
probably be refactored but that's sort
of like a a different story um but i
don't know if there's going to be any
feedback if i come by and and and give
you that but you know you're welcome to
come by and and pick it up oh you're
coming right now so i might actually
just give it to you all right thank you
sure all right anyone else let's see uh
yes there in the back
right okay so the question
i'm sorry
yeah so so yeah so you're asking if i
understand correctly you know in the
face of polymorphism um interfaces or
inheritance
you might have you know a single
interface a single abstract class but it
might actually have you know an
unbounded number of you know implement
at least more than seven yeah
um i think this is where um thinking
about you know protocols become uh
important um one of the things that i
also talk about in the book is um you
know around api design um it's quite
important to think about uh invariance
so pre and post conditions
so
right and then you know this thing
called the liskop substitution principle
tends to come in here
because if you can imagine an interface
for example you can say hey let's define
an interface that you know my client
code interacts with and i might have
various different implementations of
that interface but all the
implementations must uh you know fulfill
the same contract in the sense that you
know the invariance must remain true you
know the the preconditions and the post
conditions exposed by each of those um
each of those uh you know
implementations must be the same so the
the list of substitution principles says
that you know
things that are more derived um should
be let's say more taught it's basically
also the you know
postal law you know it must be you know
more tolerant of input or more
restrictive and output so it's sort of
like rema it keeps on
um
uh it keeps on um
fulfilling the same contract
so there's this idea of you know an
interface on abstract based class
representing a contract with some stated
rules
and and basically uh that also means
again that if you're looking at the call
side where you want to call into an
interface method
you should
you should be
you should be able to think about that
as saying well if i as a caller fulfill
the preconditions then i expect the
implementation whatever it is to you
know guarantee that the post conditions
are going to be you know what they're
supposed to be and then again you know
exactly what happens and you know which
one of the 21 implementations that i
actually end up using shouldn't really
be important at that level of
granularity so it still becomes just one
thing
if if that answers your question i know
that was a little bit of a ram you know
ramble because i was trying to figure
out you know how to sort of
answer the question um but i hope that i
gave you a decent answer there
um
if i did then please come and collect
your book
when you have the time all right um i
don't have any more books to um
to um you know hand out
uh i do have a few more minutes uh so if
if you have more questions then i'll be
happy to yes sir
is there i'm sorry
can you shout a little bit more
yeah i'm getting old my hearing is not
as good as it's supposed um
yeah so so if if i may rephrase just you
asking you know
am i did that was i am i able to follow
this you know idea throughout or you
know um does it sometimes happen that i
have to compromise on this principle for
various different reasons is that a good
you know rephrase uh you know
okay yeah sure
um i am
i think i was you know for the code base
for the book i think i was quite
successful in following the you know
this uh most of those rules almost you
know throughout and i said almost uh and
this has also been my experience with uh
with you know coaching teams and
writing all the other you know code
for production views um
it's
it's more often than not
possible to follow this design principle
but again you know it's it's an idea
it's a rule of thumb it's a guiding
principle and i don't want to make it a
hard rule that you must follow because
they could you know you will always have
edge cases uh and i respect that you
know its cases will occur but you know
in my experience you can follow this
much more than you actually thought
possible
um but again with with exceptions prop
probably
all right should we take one more and
then you can still get a you know get
out of here before uh other people or
yes
you're right okay so does this work with
you know something like clean
architecture for example um so i must
admit that i actually haven't read
robert c martin's book clean
architecture yet but lots of people are
asking about that as and as i understand
clean architecture it's it's very
reminiscent of portland adapters um and
yes i you know you know those things i i
feel you know go um very well together
all right i think i'm going to let you
off now and if if you want to talk to me
i'm i'll just hang around here and
you're welcome to come and talk to me
but thanks for coming
you